[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you know this might sound weird but
greed island is both the worst and the
best arc so far
and by that i mean i had more fun in the
first half of this arc than i did pretty
much with
any of the others and it had a brilliant
balance of emotion
action and narrative creating a
wonderful cacophony that rang
beautifully in my ears
however on the other hand
yeah this arc has some of what i thought
were the lowest points in the series in
terms of
entertainment value but it also ended up
having some of my favorite stuff out of
the series period
so what are we waiting for let's jump
into this video game that turned out to
be way more scary than i thought it
would and
way more thought out than i could have
ever anticipated
i'm toy not mark and this is my blind
review for the clunky the exciting
and intensely interesting greed
island
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but first some housekeeping for york new
city
last week i said hunter hunter from 1999
was over and the comments proceeded to
yell at me about how great island is
covered in the ovas
look i know they exist but it's not
really the same series the original 99
series and the final york new
ova were both directed by the legendary
kuzohiro furohashi
best known for rooney kenshin he has
such a distinct style and a huge number
of industry contacts that helped elevate
that series into something special
however with the greed island ovas
furahashi is
gone instead replaced by yukihiro
matsushita
and makoto sato for parts one and two
respectively while the former did an
okay job the latter was pretty atrocious
and
overall the ovas are pretty poor and i
don't think they're worth talking about
beyond
maybe the
ultimately the point is that the staff
and overall approach to the series in
both tone and animation quality is so
vastly different that a lot of people
today just don't even consider it part
of the original series
additionally on the review front as i
closed out my last video a few of you
might have felt as though the video
ended abruptly and
you know i can see why and i think
personally from a creative point of view
my writing of that ending mostly spawned
from it feeling sort of abrupt to me too
i really admired york news dedication to
the mafia style
story and i love the interactions and
choices made throughout
in some ways i really liked that the arc
ended with kurapika employing strategy
in order to avoid conflict and overall
the arc subverted many expectations in
that respect
however i do think that the arc didn't
feel like it had a definitive
ending and honestly i'm okay with that
this story feels like everything bleeds
so readily and easily into the next
that finding the dividing lines between
different arcs particularly at the end
of york knew
felt difficult and i think that's
partially why i decided to make paku
sacrifice the big climactic moment to
end that particular video on
it just felt right to me okay with that
now out of the way let's get into greed
island
i think one of the strongest aspects of
greed island is also one of its biggest
weaknesses ironic as it may sound but i
think it's true
this arc takes itself quite seriously
and as such
regarding exposition it can get quite
heavy sometimes a little down the road
but i'll touch on that a little more
later this story does take itself very
seriously and you know what i think it
should i mean it's dealing with some
truly mature subject matter with gon and
the others
and as a result tons of focus is given
to the structure of the story as well as
the game itself
without delay the arc starts and under
no circumstances are we left hanging
wondering what the spider troop or
phantom trip whatever you want to call
them will do
next the troops themselves explicitly
tell them that they aren't
after them right now due to the curse
placed on crollow it's a simple decision
to make but
it made the story that much more
digestible and enabled me
to give guns portion of the story my
full attention and speaking of
finally we get the auction that we've
all been waiting for for what feels like
a century and
once the game greed island became the
topic of the scene i was
delighted i'm supremely invested in how
gone search for his father will proceed
and
i can't wait to see what lengths this
game will push them to i also like how
gone in
almost every scene proves how perceptive
he actually
is despite him looking and acting like a
naive kid nine times out of ten he's
always got his head screwed on tight
picking up on little pieces of
information like i don't know for
instance
jing not being the seller it's not
important now but similar to when we
were on the tower
during the hunter exams gone remembers
elements that he can reapply to a later
problem
in other words i love the consistent
character writing takashi continues to
produce for him
and his other characters there are
indeed small moments like him
accidentally raising his hand and
bidding exorbitant amounts of money on
the game but
those instances are born out of
innocence not a lack of intelligence and
i think that's an important distinction
to make when gon understands what he
needs to do
he always seems to find a way out of it
in extremely creative and clever ways
and that comes to light in the opening
chapters of this very section take for
example his plan to
not actually buy the game but to instead
keep tabs on who buys it so that he can
play alongside the winning bidder after
all they don't need the game just the
data and it's a great observation
and one that makes their likelihood of
success reaching their goal
that much more realistic and that's not
all when the gentleman declines they
offer for them to play
certain that they currently are looking
for experienced hunters to participate
gone remembers that the game
can have unlimited players these are
small easily missed instances but you
best believe
very few people have this level of
applied logic at the drop of a hat
under pressure which honestly helped to
make gone a very endearing character as
i was reading kilauea might be number
one in the popularity polls in japan but
good god almighty i love gone
also i'm not sure how noteworthy or
important this will become later down
the line but
i'm a little interested in what's
happening in the background of this
story concerning killua's brother at
every
single auction he seems to be bested
when trying to bid for greed island
looking back now this could just be
tagashi's vehicle for him to establish
this exceptionally affluent individual
who ends up buying up all the copies of
the game but it seems strange to me to
use a named character
to achieve this when you could just as
easily make up a random person for that
very instance
it might be nothing but i thought it
worth mentioning in case it goes
somewhere down the line but anyway
as the boys trained to nab a spot among
those playing the game of greed island
the means with which they strive to
refine or hone their abilities borders
on the pathological
oh and after receiving some insight from
kurapika i learned that
he held chains slept with chains
looked at chains and sketched chains
like
one of his french girls for an ungodly
amount of time which suggests that
kurapika
didn't just conjure a shovel like i
thought he did for the purposes of
bearing uvo but instead
he brought one in advance um
let that sink in it's really cool
getting to see the confident and
determined kilowatt refine
and discover a special ability but gone
struggle once again
seems to be the most interesting to me
there's a particular focus on behalf of
takashi to show us that gon is amazing
time and again throughout the series
only for him to undercut himself time
and again when he's alone he doesn't
believe in himself with all of these
instances together acting as subtle
reminders that he's struggling with
self-esteem deep down
and really all of these occurrences
dotted throughout this story have to in
some way blow up at some point there's
simply being too many examples of this
behavior not to manifest in something
substantial
or a climax at some point and that's not
even all that i appreciated within this
training portion the idea that tagashi
had for empowering the two boys was
honestly brilliant having already
chapters prior established what it took
repeaka to conjure chains like he did we
now understand what the equivalent would
be for transmitters like kilauea or
enhancers like gone in other words
they couldn't possibly make up the
difference overnight and so they decided
to lean into their past traumas from
their family life killer was spent
years being shocked and tortured by his
familial circumstances and as a result
now can manifest lightning from his
fingers like some sort of sith lord
i've mentioned before that a large part
of his story comes from his
determination to blaze his own trail and
to do his own thing
away from his family however it's that
very past he's trying to move away from
that's given him this ability however on
a positive note he seems to be utilizing
that trauma to bolster his efforts
independent
of his family as far as the auditions go
both of them qualify
exceptionally easy and once gone enters
the game
the visuals are immediately
distinguishable from pretty much
everything else i've seen in the series
thus far at least in the manga the
backgrounds are intricately detailed
however thankfully
not distractingly so despite the solid
black colors in the background the
characters are always easy to make out
at a glance
making these pages exceptionally easy to
digest and that's important because
this is one of the first places where
they give us the rules of the game and
surprisingly
the game sounds pretty engaging you know
for a game that exists exclusively
within a manga series for the purposes
of a single arc from the
early 2000s once he enters the game
proper the reveal of the game world in
the manga is honestly stunningly
beautiful also with a full two-page
spread
i'm honestly so jealous i want to be
there but also not because i'd probably
almost definitely die
actually you know what that reminds me i
asked a few people what sort of nen
power they thought i might have and i
figured i'd ask you guys the same of all
the nin types which do you think
i would be given my personality or what
you know about me leave a comment down
below i'd be really interested to see
what you guys think
more on the greed island front one thing
that caught my attention before gone
entered the main area was the message he
received from
jing and the subsequent conversation he
had with kilauea about it
afterwards
because only one person can enter the
game at any given time this offered
takashi something i would never have
thought to do and it's completely
changed my impression of gone as a
character
and what i think his goal really is the
impression jing has given me is that
he's a pretty
messed up person and certainly not a
good father to put him mildly the
message he left on the cartridge that
gone
was so eager to hear made me want to
punch him in the face
he says welcome gone this is the game i
made with my friends well
go ahead and enjoy if you thought
there'd be a clue to help you find me
too bad i just wanted to show off our
game anyway now you're stuck here until
you get the item that'll let you out so
play your heart out i didn't think much
of this message from him until i heard
guns recanting
of the message back to killua when asked
about it gon says
and i quote yeah jin told me to enjoy
the game
if that's all he thought was worth
repeating from that message then i think
that speaks
volumes for gohan's mindset here
sometimes it's not what you say
but what you don't say i think he
sincerely wants to find a connection
with his father now and doesn't want to
accept that his father isn't what he
wants him to be
instead opting to accept that the
problem lies with him and maybe if he
can improve and better himself then
maybe jing will want to be his father
whatever way this story decides to take
this eventual interaction i'm
certain it will leave me in a flood of
tears
after arriving at the first town gon and
kilauea are faced with the reality of
their situation and furthermore the
consequences of this reality becomes
all the more clear and interestingly
this acts as a great opportunity for the
story to share with us some new
characters and introduce us to
the metagame or strategy some folks have
decided to employ within this world
there are those looking to kill as many
people as they can to free up the
different cards they need to collect and
then there are those that want to gain a
monopoly on the cards in circulation and
get everyone out that way
looking back at these factions and
ideologies it's clear that this game was
designed to push people into conflict
around these cards
players are supposed to hoard as many
cards as they can in whatever way they
can
living up to its name greed island
somewhat appropriate that this game was
created in part by the admittedly
selfish jin
somewhat curiously however this whole
scene with the recruiters to enlist gone
and kilauea
i thought it would be a vehicle for a
clearly defined goal moving towards the
conclusion you know i
thought they would join well that didn't
exactly happen
gone outright refuses to participate and
soon afterwards confirms my worry he
didn't join because he didn't want to
hear people bad mouthing his father's
game a game with mechanics that fosters
this sort of behavior it became clear to
me at this point that gone was
in denial with kilauea even looking
curiously at him through the side of his
eyes saying people
do die in this game you know and despite
that gone just
digs his heels in saying things like the
scariest thing isn't the game it's the
player's willingness to take cards by
hurting others
and while that observation is in a very
technical sense the case
i think this moment is possibly the most
overtly obvious and transparent gone has
been
about his father and this is a running
trend during this arc as a whole there
are numerous instances where players try
their best to survive in this game and
yet the only thing gone seems to get
angry at is how some choose to not have
fun
with the game and instead focus on their
own escape he can seem to empathize with
the positions they seem to be in
and you know what it's unsurprising
considering what we've seen from this
character throughout the story
[Music]
this is the one aspect of this arc that
i borderline
hate but just so we're clear i can
totally see someone liking the story
more
specifically because of all the things
i'm about to criticize and furthermore
i loved the material before this and i
really loved the material afterwards but
yeah
this is what i find extremely
unappealing about this arc so far
the game i don't think i've ever seen
something like greed island
ever attempted before in an anime
something like sword art online comes to
mind but that sort of cops out by making
the game work under real world logic
with limited amounts of exposition
needed to actually understand or enjoy
the game being played by the characters
it pretty much
gamifies anime something that us as an
audience already understand but
with greed island togashi
is gaming this is legitimately a game
with mechanics spells and rules and for
oh so many rules on one hand i'm
legitimately impressed like this could
actually be a game and
i think once you learn how to play it
actually could be fun however one thing
i will say is that whenever i get asked
if i'd like to play a board game with my
friends
one of the main things hold me back from
always saying yes
is the necessary or required reading
before you can play it in other words
you need to understand the rules in
order to play and i think that's one of
this arc's weakest areas
there are so so many things we need to
learn in this arc
about this game before we go into the
game we're told how it works
when we enter the game the menu girl
tells us more about how it works
when we meet the group of recruiters
they lecture us more about how the game
works and the metagame they're in
and as their scenes continue later on
down the line there's even more
information thrusted onto us as an
audience
heck chapter 134 has literally
four entire pages of just spells and
their functions
there's no artwork here and you know
what i wouldn't mind either if this was
story but it's not it's
just cards it's just cards and what they
do
i'm not reading and learning the inner
workings of a game that i'm never going
to play and i think it's really cool and
impressive that tagashi has actually
gone out of his way to make this game
but
it does come with that significant
downside with the game itself requiring
us as readers to understand how it works
scenes that would normally be written to
satisfy the showing and not telling
function of a story
are effectively put on the back burner
in favor of long stretches of dialogue
sequences as some guy
talks about a particular spell or
mechanic or whatever again
literally four pages of spells with no
artwork i can't stress enough how little
reading these pages received from me
i did not read them because i did not
want to part of me also thinks it's
hilarious by the way so i don't hate it
completely
but that's not to say that it's all
talking either although there is a lot
of explaining through dialogue in the
opening of this arc
there are instances of showing and not
telling too
take for example the exchange in chapter
133 where kilauea and gone after winning
the sword of truth
get tailed by some creeps looking to
steal their newly acquired card
the means with which gone and killerweb
avoid this card being stolen was both
fun
and informative for me i prefer to learn
by playing and not by reading i mean
even i know that the opening tutorials
of games are better suited when you play
and understand the game rather than the
game
lecturing you about how it's supposed to
be played and the same applies
in this arc and look i know i ragged
earlier on tagashi's overall convoluted
means of communicating the lore and
rules of this game to us but
that's not to say that there isn't a
tremendous and subtle play
being made during this either at every
available opportunity almost to a
pathetic
degree gone would go out of his way to
express how much fun
he's having whether that be to kill as
he anticipates what the combat might
look like or
even after something as mundane as
buying a map he's quick to make up
excuses for the dangerous or boring
elements of the game and
in the same breath condemns those that
would try their best to win
and effectively save their own lives
from it and you know what this aspect of
the arc is easily its strongest quality
for me
and that's when we get this exchange
between members of the phantom troop
after hopping into the game themselves
this was a brilliant swerve and
ironically one that conflicts with guns
current fantasyland he's currently
living in
if this is true this shatters what gone
was saying about his father but
something tells me that even more mental
gymnastics are on the horizon for our
little gong character
and without missing a step with almost
perfect comedic timing
[Music]
this is definitely my favorite section
thus far in the arc there's plenty of
gone confronting some grim truths but
there's
also this character called biscuit and
as a character i didn't expect
her to be such a nice fit for the group
and on first viewing
i never would have anticipated her to
impact the plot the way that she has
with all of the exposition over the last
20 or so chapters i was relieved to say
that we were finally getting some light
or comedic interactions with a much
smaller scope for a bit in essence the
boys are now trying to make their way
through this crowd of monsters and while
we're made aware that this little girl
looking person called biscuit is
following them
i enjoyed how even before we as an
audience were made aware of her identity
and profession
that she still continued to tail them
continuing to comment on their progress
or promise
as nen users apart from getting to see
the two boys engaged with all sorts of
strange creatures throughout this area
seeing her finally drop the act and tell
them who she really is was honestly
quite interesting
not just because it's nice to see who
we're finally dealing with but also to
get a much more accurate understanding
of how powerful some folks really are
relative to the rest and as luck would
have it she's actually a 57 year old nan
master of sorts
she taught wing everything he knows back
in the day and now she wants to help
teach the boys
okay i'm game yeah let's do this
wait they need to deal with him alright
so the current objective right now is to
defeat this man she just defeated in
moments
within a two-week time limit none of
them can leave the area
if the two boys fail they get punished
and if he fails then he gets killed by
biscuit
now this right from the outset was
interesting to me for one prevailing
reason with a stipulation like that it's
tailor-made to deliver one specific
conclusion
a conclusion that shows how much more
adept in the combat sense gun and
kilauea have become as well as to give
them a chance to shine from an emotional
standpoint also
gone has no malice for this guy despite
what she's told him about him
and throughout this fight we get a sort
of peek into his past living in the
slums and struggling there but
despite knowing this gone won't finish
him even after he gives up
it's a great sequence but to be honest
the end of it was my favorite with
biscuit remarking that he's a flawless
specimen
and it makes him a delicate balance now
that sounds surprisingly similar to
how the appraiser described gone earlier
that is not a coincidence
and that's when we get to the training
portion of this story
the training portion of the story is
easily its strongest section from a pure
enjoyment standpoint for me
i love the biscuit character what she
represents as a goal and
what sort of challenges or obstacles she
places in front of kilowatt and gone
sleeping with a rock hoisted above their
head digging through a mountain
fighting different wild animals all of
these are such
fun ideas and gave me much needed
respite from the prior exposition heavy
sections
and to be honest sections like this can
only exist when the exposition is gotten
out of the way
take any popular work whenever you're
feeling like you're getting a lot of
words or explanations thrown at you
oftentimes at least if the story is
halfway decent it's an indication that
there's something impressive coming up
later
and normally this takes the form of a
big page spread or a nice action
sequence or something but instead
takashi it seems decided to stretch out
that garnered time in the form of a
training mini arc
and while i didn't enjoy all of the
clunky explanations earlier i did very
much enjoy this portion of the story
centered around gone's training and
curiously too
biscuit remarks to herself that the game
greed island if played in the correct
order
naturally makes the player stronger and
she perhaps
correctly reckons that jing made it like
this perhaps
to train his son this would answer my
question that i posed in the first york
new video where i asked if jing is so
gung-ho on never being found or meeting
up with gon
why did he leave all of that stuff
behind in the first place and the answer
to that that biscuit seems to be
satisfied with
is so that gone can get stronger the
implications of which i'm not sure if i
want to read into
does jing want a fight gone right so
while all of that is happening the
subplot between the large group that
wanted to combat the murderers of the
game with a monopoly of cards resumes
and i'm all so grateful for how this one
ended
at the moment there are currently four
plot threads going on right now the
phantom trip uncovering the truth of the
island the monopoly gang
the killers of the game and of course
golden killer was training under biscuit
and half of these i don't care at all
about
those being the killers of the game and
the lads looking to organize monopoly
ideally one would be at least a little
interested in all of these stories to
various degrees but
these just didn't do it for me though
tagashi does
fix this eventually how well by having
the killers infiltrate the monopoly
crowd steal
all of their cards and
i love how this scene was handled it
focuses on a small collection of three
characters as they weasel their way into
the position of power
before ultimately betraying and
deceiving everyone that trusted them
this gives us a clear point of conflict
for golden kilowatt to run up against
eventually give us a goal
as an audience and it helped us
understand and better get to know the
individuals involved overall i'm
delighted with this creative decision
things are far more simple now and the
story feels
all the better for it and this isn't
even my favorite part of the story
throughout this tale a minor subplot
concerning certain members of the
phantom troop and the greed island video
game has yielded brief but
fascinating moments of intrigue for me
completely recontextualizing the entire
occasion as
not a game but instead a teleporter to a
real life
island closely monitored by some spooky
and imposing individual
that claims to be one of the creators of
the game before eating everyone away
that didn't enter in the correct fashion
and furthermore
he probably knows about jing so let's
freaking go maybe this greed island game
wasn't a complete waste of time for gone
after all
i wonder if this guy will actually end
up coming into contact with gone at some
point
i hope he does one of the most important
aspects of a training arc is to visibly
see
in no uncertain terms the progression
made by the trained individual
it's basic and we see it in pretty much
every trainiac's conclusion
we sought after the time skip in dragon
ball when goku arrives the tournament
all grown up and hella strong we saw it
in erin yeager's fantastic 3d
maneuvering in episode 4 and we saw it
numerous times throughout my hero
academia
point is we gotta see as an audience
that oh
so delicious contrast from what once was
to what is now
and boy do we see that in greed island
lingering in the back of my mind all
this time was
just when exactly is takashi going to
have kilauea get his hunter's license
partially i was thinking about this
because yeah surely he doesn't want us
to sit through yet
another copy of the exact same story
again and
while we did retread some familiar and
you know admittedly in nostalgic
territory killua made sure that his was
a brief affair
with the very first phase proving to be
little challenge
to the young boy eliminating literally
everyone who participated at once and
achieving his license there and then and
upon his return
kilauea says the hilarious line it took
me longer to get here than it did to get
the license
and that's not even the craziest part of
this entire section
when kilauea arrives back and regains
his bearings with the group check out
what happens when kilowatt looks at
their recent encounters list
okay so now this story has gone from
good to the most interesting i've
encountered so far
while this story did have a rather rough
start boasting some of the most
arduous and clunky narrative portions
from the series
i genuinely think this story
particularly in its latter stuff
makes full use of characters that were
established in the prior material
and has massive stakes both in terms of
the lives at risk and in terms of
personal investment
we've gone from a game that was once
made by some guy to a game that will
kill you and then to a game that will
kill you but isn't really a game but
instead a teleporter to a particular
island in the real world this is like
lost or something this is a really crazy
revelation and it's
brilliant and now we learn hisoka is
here as crollo's proxy
this is insane and can i just say my
favorite drawing in this portion so far
has to be this drawing of crolo from
chapter 149 tagashi seems to really love
how this character looks and how pretty
he is seems really important to him
because he receives
as a character the best treatment in the
manga visually far above everyone else
now i haven't gone back over the manga a
tremendous amount to make this claim but
it seems to me when i'm reading it that
krolow is drawn with like different
materials or if one character takes five
minutes to draw it's like takashi spends
about 15 minutes to half an hour drawing
krolo he's always like
super rendered or super well drawn and
never drawn poorly or at least not that
i've seen
anyways it's cool to see krollo back so
soon and in such a creative way
i'm delighted to see what's to come from
this and additionally
i'd like to know how he got a console
with a game in the first place
this is only the first half of this arc
naturally and i loved what this arc has
become
and the direction it's going next week
i'll be reading the rest of what this
arc has to offer and i really hope it
can stick the landing to what i think
it's gearing up for fingers crossed i
can but regardless
i can't wait to share my thoughts on it
with you all next week i've been totally
not mark
thank you so much for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]